[Music]
can you hear me yeah I guess so
so I will be walking during the
presentation so feel free to tell me if
I'm not here to well at the end so I'm a
software engineer I did some data
science also had some free time recently
and I like learning things especially
learning things the hard way
so when I had this free time I decided I
will read some books and I will learn
how to understand deep learning so I
also watched some videos and after some
time I I could say like Donald Trump
there is nobody like me who knows more
about deep learning but then so what is
the deep learning I will get it's not
working so what is the deep learning
it's a kind of powerful machine learning
model that can approximate almost every
function almost inside it's just a deep
neural network and it's kind of good on
recognizing patterns and oh wait it's
relatively quick to learn to teach the
model with massive amounts of data and
it's good at recognizing patterns and
this is what makes it very efficient for
speech like recognition natural language
processing image recognition especially
okay that's all about deep learning
because I think that one third of this
conference is about deep learning so
that's all you need to know so I want to
talk more about reinforcement learning
and you know what is the reinforcement
learning famous for right it's the Atari
games
by the computer there are also some
other examples like alphago like
autonomous vehicles or or the games of
course so so in reinforcement learning
we teach machines how to act by trial
and error okay to understand a bit more
or more formally there are two examples
to understand reinforcement learning and
trade-offs in it so first one is the
multi-armed bandit problem so we assume
that we've got Cocina and there is there
are slot machines like for here I
entered the casino and I don't want
don't know which one to play so I need
to choose one to play and then I will
have some reward if I if I win the game
but at the beginning I don't know the
underlying distributions of the slot
machines and also I iteratively repeat
the process so I will play forever in
this casino and what I want to do of
course is to optimize my rewards over
time second example is the maze problem
so I'm in a maze I can move left right
front back and I need to find the way
out so that's kind of similar I've got
some state I need to take actions and
I've got some reward reward either now
or at the end of the maze and maze is
that a monistic while multi-armed bandit
is non-deterministic okay so after this
intuition we need we can introduce some
concepts so first concept is an
environment so environment has some
state that I know or I don't know I can
reset it it it today like initial site
State and I can take some actions and
with each action
I will get some reward also there is
actions rewards and there is return
return which is usually some kind of sum
over rewards I get and I got at each
state okay so that's the so generally
reinforcement learning is solving
problems that are specified by the
environment by using the actions and my
goal is to optimize my return so what do
I need to do this and there is like the
most important concept in reinforcement
learning when when it comes to solving
the problems it's Q function so Q
function is a simple mathematical
functions that given a state and an
action will tell me what is my expected
return if I choose this action right so
actually if I know the Q function I know
how to act in this maze I just need to
optimize my expected reward yeah so
every time I see a state I ask the Q
function what's the best action for the
state and I chooses to choose the action
of course I don't know the Q function
because like in the maze I'm in the
middle of the maze I don't know where is
my goal and I don't know if going right
or left is better for me what's the
expected reward sorry
return but there are some small games
and I can compute the comp the Q
function I will just go around the maze
and I will update iteratively the Q
function and many of the q function will
converge like if I use the procedure as
on the slide like like I said q s of a
to be equal to the reward I get to lose
plus the expected
what I get from calling the same
function I will if I use this procedure
the my algorithm will converge to the
true Q I can use also more smooth
version of updating q function and it's
very helpful if the Q is
non-deterministic or if the step in
environment is non-deterministic
okay so what's actually deep
reinforcement learning so it's just
learning Q with deep learning so Q is
like there is too many states to know
the Q but I can try to approximate it
with deep learning and coming to the end
of the the long introduction about what
reinforcement learning is and and what
it which problems it solves I need to
tell you about two main directions in
reinforcement learning so one is towards
universal intelligence or we may call it
AI and this is we want to create the an
algorithm which is going to learn very
fast a new environment and will be good
in playing in this an environment it's
like I will teach my algorithm on a
single Atari game and I want it to learn
the new game very much faster than
learning the game from scratch okay so
that's that's a direction towards
general AI but there is also another
direction in reinforcement learning and
it's I want to solve real problems with
reinforcement learning so I will create
my own environment I will create the
rewards and I expected that the outcome
of the play in the environment will be
usable in other applications like
autonomous driving
so following that direction I started to
think about how to solve the cube and it
is the hard way because actually when I
use tutorials to learn something new in
tutorials everything is simple and
everything in work everything works and
when I solve some hard problem I
understand that in real world nothing is
simple and nothing works ok so let's
talk about the cube so the cube has
really a lot of states you can see it on
the on the screen and it's the number is
so big that we could encode every word
in a single state of the cube or
actually every word in every language
and there is still space in the cube for
too long numbers right so you can see
that's to the power 10 to the power of
19 like enormous number and why is it
interesting it's interesting because
because I can solve every cube in 20
moves or 26 depends on how do you count
it okay
and also the basic algorithm that you
know from I don't know from school or
from from internet it's usually about
120 moves so if you start with one wall
then you start with first layer and so
on it's usually about 120 moves and
what's interesting that we know that the
cube is solvable in 20 moves but we
don't know how unless we use brute force
and that's actually how people proved
that it's 20 moves that it's in that is
enough because they have just like
enumerated all the states and for each
state they observe that is only 20 moves
okay so I started like taking tutorial
to reinforcement learning and trying to
create an environment to solve the cube
in the optimal way and what actually
what was actually the result so I
created the rewards one when it solved
zero when it's not
I like coded the cube like cube is just
six walls every wall is three times
three and every square can be in one of
four six colors so it's it's a tensile
like this and I also needed to define
actions so action is just choosing a
wall and then choosing a rotation ref
left or right twelve actions so of
course it turns out to perform totally
badly like because what is reinforcement
learning like reinforcement learning
will go through the states of the cube
and if it solves it will get reward but
actually you know how much states there
is so solving by walking randomly and
the cube is totally impossible so yeah
so then you realize that actually deep
reinforcement learning is not a solution
to all problems we have and actually
it's not a black box so I was thinking
what can I do better and there is two
peels blue and red in red one you can
tune the parameters of underlying neural
network you can add more CPUs and GPUs
and add more layers to new network or
you can choose the blue pill but let let
me say you why the red one is bad tuning
parameters is almost every time but if
you don't know what's going on
underneath and adding CPUs and GPUs make
it makes the problem more complex or you
don't understand what's going on on the
on these CPUs and
it's the same with layers in the network
so what I did was I dig deeper into the
algorithm I also tried to solve a
smaller problem like a cube that has
only two two squares on each side and
scramble the cube only for example three
times like yeah you can imagine that and
also I could see what others did and at
the end you come to think what is
actually the tough part of the problem
okay so first how we train the
underlying network and that's so you
probably know that we trained trained
the neural network in batches so I take
some budgets I compute the gradient and
I changed the wages to word tor towards
the better solution let's assume I've
got a maze like this so it's actually
binary tree for a full one not every
ages a edge is on the screen but it's
working like this you can go left or
right and to get the reward equal to one
you get two you need to go first right
and then left
to the end or first left and then right
and then right forever like so what
happens if my batch size is free let's
suppose and I'm in the states a so I'm
going another few steps and I'm teaching
the network's with my last moves which
were good and they were all left so what
is the neural net learning is learning
that there is some state but actually
going all the time left is a good
strategy and then I choose a batch after
going to the B state and I try to teach
it with going all the way right
and I trained the network like going
cried is the good strategy so it will
never converge so we need to think at
the beginning how we train the network
so there is something that is called
replay memory so it's not the case that
I am walking in the state space I'm just
having some memory that I put States or
actually transitions to it a transition
is a state in action the next state and
the reward reward and I use the state's
sampled from the memory to train the
network and memory is actually just a
cyclic buffer of transitions of course I
need to use random batches and when I do
this what happens to my cube
how is my neural net solving the cube so
I've got some state this is an action
I've got next States I get some reward
and this is this four is the transition
so I will put every transition in memory
then I sample it and then I try to teach
my network with the samples so first of
all I need to think of the exploration
versus exploitation trade-off so if I've
got for example almost everything solved
in a cube like first wall
I've got two walls and then in cube
sometimes I have to break some walls to
solve it so I need to explore states
that appear not to be optimal for me and
and what that means is that I need to
have in memory stir states that are
close to being solved because I want the
network to learn about the states that
are close to being solved solved
because this states gives me much more
knowledge and also what's different in
cube to Atari games is actually in other
games when you play bad you will lose
fast in not in cube you if you play bad
the cube you will never finish it right
so playing bad means you will have you
will play a lot of time before without
any reward while playing good gives you
like quick reward so the situation is a
bit different so I added also max steps
parameter so if my neural networks tries
to solve the cube in more than for
example 10 10 moves I will just restart
it from I will say it's not solved and
to understand what what is going on I
will speak a bit of the algorithm so how
I choose the next action to take so with
some probability I will choose a random
a random move and this is because I want
to explore different states and at some
probability I will just choose the best
best action that is chosen by my model
that is quite simple and also I want to
have something like with time the
probability of going randomly decreases
and the main loop of the algorithm is I
have some state some starting state are
you reset the environment
I get the state I choose the action I
have next state reward and I know if the
game has finished I will push this
transition to memory I will change the
state and I will optimize the model
that's like how I train the network
and what else I need I've got some deep
Q Network underlying so and I've got
some prop parameters of the learning so
I need to think how does the random walk
probability decreases over time I need
to think what is actually my reward of
choosing any action and I also want to
tune the batch size and learning rate
okay so we can also think of tuning the
model and usually we start with three
linear layers we can try adding some
convolutional convolution some batch
normalization drop out these are
standard techniques you do for the
planning but oh yeah you can also tune
the parameters carefully but after
thinking about bit of it it turns out
that that setting the rewards is more
important because you've got if I have
only zero on or one actually the the
algorithm needs to learn 25 moves to get
to the reward that's clearly too too
many moves so you try to add some some
rewards negative rewards with every step
or you want to think on of how many
percent do you have to solve the cube
like you can calculate it in two ways
like this I've got this is fully compute
for the soft wall
this is fully soft wall this one is I
would say around sixty percent salt wall
right so I can say it like this or I can
compute the number of walls that are
solved but actually I checked both and
it turns out they that both district
wars appear to be bad in training
because they
actually tell us they are meaningful
only two moves be before finishing
because yeah you can think of it why
this reward is bad and at the same time
you want to minimize the number of moves
and there is yet another problem when
you start to analyze what is the cube
and how should this neural network learn
to solve the cube you understand the
represent that the representation is
kind of hard also
because you start with one and holding
colors because usually one hot encoding
is better than then playing numbers but
then you realize that the the states you
get are not very they are changing not
they are changing in a way weird way
when you represent it this way
because you want to represent the cube
using the symmetry and so that learning
simple argyll algorithms is easy for the
cube so what are the results so one word
is disappointing I would say because
it's you will have my code so you will
you will be able to see it you can have
like solving cubes for example 4 5 6
moves with some high probability and I
found a paper or a blog post that the
guy is saying he can solve I eight moves
but he is not using reinforcement
learning just that for the traditional
deep learning but there are still some
takeaways from this this experiment so
first you right now I will publish my
codes so you have almost everything to
start experimenting with reinforcement
learning there are also other
environments
which are simpler you don't need a GPU
for that actually because what I
observed that in deep learning in many
cases you need a lot of GPUs and in
reinforcement learning it's often the
case that there is that that changing
the states and making the actions takes
a lot CPU you cannot move it to GPU so
it starts to be a bottleneck so from
switching to GPUs you get speed up like
like about just three times faster
that's not that much and there is still
a lot to do like you can improve the the
solving the how to solve the cube and
like there is why to do this the
question so I think like looking at the
job offers right now so most of them say
that we are a company building some
software and we use a bit of AI so and
actually this AI is like the sport tires
in a Cinquecento often and it's going to
be different that there will be no
software without AI and so it's good to
understand what's going on underneath
yeah and last thing a few things that
were great there is a course on fast AI
website that is I would say great and if
you have like for me it was better than
watching serials in the evenings because
this guy is doing something oh we've got
a Cargill competition that was run two
years ago and actually the top two any
solutions were very hard like examples
of different models but I will show you
a solution using deep learning in 20
lines of code and he shows you it and
like it works
there are also some posts on
medium you can see emergent future there
is like tutorial for reinforcement
learning and it's quite good
and there is a lot of stuff in pi PI
torch caressed and for tensorflow
tutorials and there was deep our L
bootcamp on Stanford or Berkeley I think
so there is a lot of videos there and
you can check my github tomorrow when I
publish the code we've got still two
minutes right or no yeah
any questions oh no maybe one question
would be did you try like gradually
increase the difficulty of initial steps
a new training procedure because it's
like six natural to train a network at
the beginning with a simple cases and
then like move towards yeah so I did it
so I trained my network at the beginning
with after scrambled and a cube only to
two moves and so on three and so on
yeah and then I kept in the eye there
were not many technical details in the
presentation but I kept in the reply
memory like I wanted to balance the
states that are in the replay memory so
that all the time there are some states
that are very close to being solved
because I don't what didn't want the
network to to forget about them it gets
tucked around yeah yeah because that's
the problem with the states you've got
2012 states that are one step away from
solved it where 12 times 12 144 two
steps and then there is much much more
steps with every move so so yeah thanks
you
[Applause]
you